major news today in regards to the
future of the MCU but we're not talking
about heroes we are talking about
anti-heroes how's it going everybody
it's Warren and a lot of people have
suspected that the Thunderbolts would be
entering the MCU for some time now and
now it appears that that is confirmed
and the Thunderbolts could even start to
assemble as early on as the very first
movie of phase 4 that's right Black
Widow today it has been reported and
confirmed that the Thunderbolts have
officially began development over at
Marvel Studios and this report comes
from MCU cosmic comm it is pointed out
that since the Avengers are gone there
really isn't a team of superheroes
anymore in the MCU there's just a bunch
of individual heroes but nobody working
together as a team the Thunderbolts
aren't really superheroes that really a
group of reformed super villains and in
the comics although they appeared to be
super villains turned good they were
actually the Masters of evil in disguise
but most of them ended up turning good
in the long run and over the past few
years the MCU has set up quite nicely
the arrival of the Thunderbolts and the
comics one group of the Thunderbolts is
led by Baron Zemo who of course we know
is going to be returning in the Falcon
and the Winter Soldier series another is
led by Thunderbolt Ross who also happens
to be Red Hulk so lots of exciting
things come into the MCU and we really
already know the lineup of the
Thunderbolts so recently we got leaked
photos from the set of Black Widow where
we can see Thunderbolt Ross now although
we are not 100% sure of what Thunderbolt
Ross is doing in the Black Widow movie
it is highly speculated that he is
recruiting Black Widow to join the
Thunderbolts and when I say Black Widow
I'm talking about the new Black Widow
we're going to see in the Black Widow
film Yelena Bulova this will be
Natasha's sister who will clearly have
gotten in some sort of trouble in the
MCU and Thunderbolt Ross could be there
offering her a plea deal same thing that
was offered to Natasha to join shield so
Thunderbolt Ross could be there to say
join the Thunderbolts and we'll mark
your ledger clean so Black Widow could
be the first recruit for the
Thunderbolts along with Thunderbolt Ross
himself as Red Hulk and then of course
like I mentioned before we will have
Baron Zemo who is going to be the main
villain of the Falcon and Winter Soldier
series there's a chance that at some
point in time during Falcon
when her soldier Thunderbolt Ross could
offer the same type of deal to Baron
Zemo
however if Baron Zemo joins he will most
likely only be putting on an act he will
most likely still be evil but be
pretending to be good but of course he
will have ulterior motives and then we
have ghosts from ant-man and the wasp in
the beginning of the movie she was kind
of bad but of course as we all saw by
the end of the movie she had turned good
for the most part but we do know that
she was on the run at the end of ant-man
and the wasp so perhaps Thunderbolt Ross
shows up and offers her the same type of
plea deal as the others and then of
course we have Justin Hammer we haven't
seen him since Iron Man 2 most likely
because he's in jail but perhaps he gets
the same offer and joins the
Thunderbolts and then to top it all off
last but definitely not least the Winter
Soldier now Bucky was framed in civil
war but he's not exactly on the best
terms with the government and he
committed a lot of crimes as the Winter
Soldier more than the rest of them did
so he's not going to get away from the
repercussions of that that easily and if
this ends up being the Thunderbolts team
we have quite a team to look forward to
in the MCU Red Hulk Black Widow
Baron Zemo Justin Hammer ghost and the
Winter Soldier now one thing that has
not been confirmed yet is whether or not
this is going to be made into a movie or
into a Disney Plus series Marvel has
options now and a lot of potential with
the Disney Plus shows it's been stated
plenty of times that everything that
happens in the Marvel Disney Plus shows
will affect the movies these shows are
in the MCU and Kevin Feige has even
stated recently that you're going to
have to watch these shows to know what
happens in the MCU so they are very
important to the plot of all of the
movies that are going to be released
from here on out but either way this is
an awesome group of anti-heroes so let
me know what you think about this group
in the comments down below and let me
know if there's anybody else that you
would like to see join the Thunderbolts
I'm still doing my xbox one and ps4
giveaway all you have to do to enter
that giveaway is be subscribed to my
channel like this video and comment
below with your favorite superhero or
villain as always thank you all so much
for watching woof woof